[Musique]
une gare entièrement rénové et un
tramway qui redessine l' architecture de
la ville de manière significative depuis
plusieurs années besançon fait peau
neuve
une politique de l'agglomération engagé
dans un programme d'aménagement urbain
destiné à transformer totalement l'avis
de la vieille cité bisontine
ces transformations sont liés simplement
à la satisfaction des besoins le besoin
logement le besoin développement
d'activités le besoin également de
travailler sur les flux et les
déplacements est le tramway finalement a
été une sorte de trait d'union entre
différents projets majeurs qui sont
reliés et que le tram va permettre de
développer au moins une dizaine de
programmes de construction ou
d'aménagement répartis dans toute la
ville à commencer par la démolition de
la première barre d'immeuble des 408
prévues ces prochaines semaines
ces mille logements neufs dans le
quartier dévêtent ou la transformation
de l'ancien casernement vauban en
espaces de bureaux de commerces et de
logements
la livraison de la zone commerciale de
chalezeule au bout de la ligne de tram
celle du musée des beaux-arts l'automne
prochain un inventaire dont les
chantiers sont pour beaucoup déjà lancé
cette année la priorité c'est de trouver
la bonne articulation entre le
développement économique
les activités et la capacité à se loger
dans une logique de déplacement qui soit
la plus raisonnée possible la ville
concentre 80% des emplois elle concentre
une bonne partie de la population
également et il est assez logique que on
travaille dans son renouvellement à
trouver des solutions pour rapprocher le
lieu où on réside et le lieu où on
travaille une politique volontaire pour
inciter la population bisontine à se
réapproprier le coeur de la cité la
priorité selon les élus d'inverser le
mouvement naturel des habitants du
centre-ville vers la périphérie
nous avons l'ambition de créer de
l'emploi des activités de conforter le
quartier universitaire du campus de
centre-ville doit être sera confortée en
lien avec l'université et or il ya eu
des travaux récents pour créer le
l'amphithéâtre de la maison des sciences
de l'homme et de l'environnement la msha
il ya tout un plan de réhabilitation des
locaux il ya la perspective de rapatrier
le cla sur le site ici de saint jacques
le projet d'une cité des savoirs et de
l'innovation
considéré comme la pièce maîtresse du
futur besançon l'ancien hôpital saint
jacques et sa grande médiathèque
régional destiné à structurer bientôt
tout le coeur de la boucle bisontine pas
demain mais c'est aujourd'hui qu'on
prépare ses projets qu'on les mette au
point qu'on monte les plans de
financement pour un plan qui va se
dérouler sur une dizaine d'années
pour l'heure les pelleteuses sont déjà à
l'oeuvre pour convertir l'usiné rhodia
c'est à un parc de loisirs pendant que
le quartier viotte se prépare lui à
devenir le grand pôle tertiaire de
besançon d'ici 2020 la vision d'une
future métropole urbaine pour l'ancienne
capitale régionale